>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good afternoon.
Friends of the Library of
Congress, students, staff,
everyone who is joining
us live on the Library
of Congress' YouTube channel,
I'm Colonel Karen Lloyd,
I'm the Director the
Veterans' History Project here
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you for taking time
out of your busy schedules
to come see New York Times'
best-selling author, Liza Mundy,
who's going to discuss her book,
Code Girls, the untold story
of American women
codebreakers of World War II.
As many of you know, we were
planning to hold this event
at the beginning of the month.
Mother nature intervened.
So, we are here a few weeks
later and more determined
than ever to shine
a spotlight on women
who have made major
contributions to our society.
We know that it's never too late
to celebrate the accomplishments
of women, and I'd like to thank
the Librarian of Congress,
Dr. Carla Hayden, and her
entire leadership team
for their commitment to
helping us with this endeavor.
I would also like to thank
Doug Bennett [assumed spelling]
for returning to Washington
to be with us today.
Today's events will
focus, not just on women,
but on women veterans, who
raised their right hand,
took an oath to support
and defend our country,
put on a uniform, and achieved
some amazing accomplishments
while during -- while
enduring many sacrifices.
You're going to hear
their stories today,
and hopefully you will learn
about others in your studies,
or through the many
resources we have here
at the Library of Congress.
As you do, keep in mind
that there are thousands more
women veterans whose names
and stories may never be
heard unless you reach
out to the veterans in your
lives in your communities
to listen, really listen to
their story, and then donate it
to the Library of Congress.
The Veterans' History
Project would also
like to thank our cosponsor, the
library's Young Reader Center.
Devoted to the reading
interests of children and teens,
the Young Reader Center
offers young people
and their families
the opportunity
to experience the
wonders and resources
of the nation's library
through ongoing programs
and special events.
They were instrumental in
helping us reach out to schools
so that their students will
benefit from today's talk,
and to develop a deeper
appreciation for primary sources
that are available to
them here at the library,
but especially the
Veterans' History Project.
With more than 105,000
collections in our archives,
the Veterans' History Project
collects, preserves and,
most importantly, makes
accessible the story
of United States military
veterans who served
in World War I through
the current conflicts
so that future generations
may hear directly
from those veterans and
better understand their
selfless service.
Our collections include video
and audio oral history
interviews,
along with original photographs,
letters, military documents,
diaries, journals, and
two-dimensional art.
We are not -- we not only
highlight our existing
collections, but we continue
to solicit volunteers like you,
from across the nation, to
gather their stories of veterans
and their lives so that their
first-person reminisces,
personal philosophies,
and creativity are
preserved for posterity.
In doing so, we all better
understand our history.
Today's guest presenter
can attest to the value
of our collections,
because she used them
when conducting research
for her book.
As a former longtime reporter
at the Washington Post,
Liza Mundy is no
stranger to research.
A senior fellow at New
America, her exploration
of issues related to women in
war, resulted in her emerging
as one of the nation's
foremost experts on the subject.
She is a frequent commentator
on prominent national
television shows, radio,
and online news outlets.
She has contributed to
numerous publications,
including The Atlantic, Time,
The New Republic, Slate,
Mother Jones, and Politico.
Now, there's a range.
In addition to Code Girls,
Liza is also the author
of The Richer Sex,
how the new majority
of female breadwinners is
transforming sex, love,
and family, and also,
Michelle, a biography.
After her presentation, Liza
has graciously agreed to stay
with us for little while
to answer questions
from the audience and to
sign copies of her book,
which are available for
purchase outside this room.
Now, please join me in welcoming
to the podium our very
special guest, Liza Mundy.
[ Applause ]
>> Liza Mundy: Thank you so
much, Wendy [assumed spelling],
for that great introduction.
Thank you everybody who came
for the rescheduled event.
Thank you, Lisa Taylor.
You've been incredibly
hospitable and organized
in both helping with my research
and organizing this event.
It's such a thrill to speak
at the Library of Congress,
obviously, one of the
great research institutions
in the world, particularly
because the Veterans'
History Collection here was
so fundamental and
crucial to my research.
When I was getting started
researching Code Girls,
and when I was, in fact,
shopping the book proposal
to editors in New
York, apparently one
of the editors said
that he thought
that it was a great
story, but that he felt
that it might be thin beer,
because so much time had
passed since World War II.
If there were any women
codebreakers out there,
they would be in their
mid-90's, you know,
maybe wouldn't remember much,
maybe there wouldn't be much
of a record since it
was top secret work.
So, I literally got up every day
during my research and thought,
I'll show you thin beer.
And, fortunately, I
had the help of allies,
like the Veterans'
History collection here.
I literally just e-mailed
through the website saying,
I'm working on this book.
Do you have anything?
I instantly got a reply from
Megan Harris saying, yes,
we have wonderful records.
We have oral histories.
We have supplementary materials.
She provided me with a
list of the names of women
that they had taken their
oral histories from,
incredibly well organized.
I came here for, you know,
several days and listened
and read to the -- to the women
who had told their stories,
many of them are no longer
with us but, fortunately,
their stories have been
collected and reside here,
and many of them are
available digitally.
And, so, in the end, I was able
to collect almost more material
than I could cope with
in reporting this book,
both from living women and from
wonderful archival resources,
like this collection, and able
to substantiate the
recollections of women
who are still alive with the
paper record with oral histories
of other women and other
supplementary information.
So, I'm so grateful
to this institution
for facilitating research,
for making American history
accessible to researchers,
to citizens, to everybody,
and then for holding events
like this where, you
know, we can continue
to get the message out,
and for supporting authors,
which is very important.
So, it's really thrilling
to be here.
It's also very thrilling
to be here during
women's history month.
Originally, I was going to
be speaking at the beginning
of women's history month, and
now we've managed to squeak
in the rescheduled event
when it's still March,
and that's really very
meaningful, because I think
that we are at, really, a
watershed moment in terms
of receptivity to
women's history.
Of course, every month should
be women's history month.
It should be everybody's
history month.
But, this month does
have a special meaning.
And I do think we're
at a great moment.
I think books like Hidden
Figures, that have been
so successful in opening
up the contributions
that women have made to
American military history,
to American science, have
really persuaded publishers
that there's an audience
for these books,
that people are receptive
to these stories.
You may know that the New York
Times has started a new series
called Overlooked, in
which they're going back
through their archival
record and they're realizing
that incredibly important
women passed from the scene
and did not get obituaries,
including Charlotte Bronte.
Women of, you know, of that
stature were not recognized
during their time.
And, so, the New York Times
has this great new series
in which they're going back and
they're providing the obituaries
of women who should've gotten
recognition in their time,
and I feel as though the
publishing industry is doing the
same thing today.
And, so, it's thrilling
to be part of it.
And, so, when talking about Code
Girls, about these thousands
of women who came to Washington
to join the U.S. military
and support the war effort,
I like to start with this --
with this slide, because it
really illustrates the plight
of the educated woman in 1942.
This photo shows the May
Court at Goucher College
in the spring of 1942.
Some of you may know,
Goucher College, back then,
was an all-girl school.
The women who went there
were called Goucher girls,
and located in downtown
Baltimore,
D.C. It's now a coeducational
University in suburban Towson.
But, at the time, it
was a city school.
Many of the young women who
attended there were city girls,
who grew up in Baltimore,
who walked to classes,
in some cases couldn't afford
to board because, of course,
they had grown up during the
depression, and who were very,
very devoted and motivated
to get a great four-year
liberal arts education.
Goucher was a very
well-respected university.
It's Dean, Dorothy Stimson, was
a noted expert on Copernicus.
The English professor,
Ola Winslow,
was the first American woman
to win a Pulitzer Prize
for her biography.
So, top-notch faculty,
very top school.
And these young women
were even more unusual
than they would've known,
because at this time
in American life, only 4%
of American women attained
a four-year college degree.
And the reason that percentage
was so small was, in part,
because so many schools
were still closed to women.
So, many campuses
did not admit women.
The Ivy league, for the most
part, was closed to women.
Many, many private universities,
many state universities.
In my home state of
Virginia, the University
of Virginia did not
give full degrees
to women really until
the 1960's.
And, so, there were --
there were not a lot of
institutions to choose from.
And, of course, these wonderful
women's colleges had been
founded in the late
19th century,
at a time when many
people believed
that higher education
was bad for women,
that it made women sort of,
you know, uppity and obnoxious.
And there was actually a belief
that education wasn't good
for women, too much learning
wasn't good for women.
There was a Harvard
physician who argued
that too much education made
women infertile, that it --
that it swelled their brains
at the expense of their wombs.
He literally our argued
that, and people believed it.
So, these women colleges,
like Goucher, had been created
at a time when they
had something to prove.
They felt that they had to prove
that women deserved
an education,
that it was worth educating
women, and that it was good
for women to be educated.
But, of course, another
reason that the numbers were
so small is that
families realized
that there was not
an economic payoff
to educating a daughter the
way that there was for a son,
because the professional
fields open
to educated women
were so limited.
If you were a woman who was
motivated to become a doctor
or a lawyer or an architect or
a businesswoman or an engineer
or a scientist, you
would be lucky
to find a spot in
a graduate school.
Many, many graduate schools
were closed to women.
Many fields were
virtually closed to women.
And, so, the only job you
could expect graduating
from a fine college really
reliably was teaching school,
and that's great if you
want to be a schoolteacher.
But, if there's another field
that you're interested in,
then it prevents a very narrow
field of endeavor for women.
And even then, only until you
get married can you expect a
school teaching job.
Back then there was something
called a marriage bar.
And, so, if a woman got
married she was required
to quit teaching, you
know, and to stay home
with her husband and her family.
So, there wasn't a
great economic payoff
to getting a college
degree for women.
And parents, again, coming out
of the depression, you know,
they made that calculation.
Now, of course, the other reason
for a woman to go to college,
for which there might
be an economic payoff,
was to get the proverbial
MRS degree,
which was a thing back then.
The idea that if you went to
college then you can date men
at neighboring men's schools.
You could marry a man
from a good family
or with good prospects,
you know,
and you could get
yourself situated in life.
Maybe you would teach for
a couple years to put him
through law school or whatever,
but that there would be an
economic payoff to marriage.
And, so, these young women, who
were academically motivated,
who were very challenged
by their classes,
were also very pressured,
particularly
in their senior year, to
get engaged, you know,
to get that ring, to have
their future assured.
And, so, these schools had
ceremonies, like the May Court.
Now, as far as I can tell,
the May Court was some sort
of remnant of a pagan fertility
ritual in which the young women,
you know, selectively,
presumably because of their
beauty or their personality
or their family or their --
or their academic standing,
would be elected
to the May Court.
You see the queen up there in
the chair and they would be sort
of symbolically ushered
into the marriage market,
and all of the women's
colleges had rituals like this.
Wellesley College
in Massachusetts had the
senior class Hooproll.
And the -- and the
legend of the Hooproll was
that the winner would be
the class' first bride.
So, that was the
great distinction.
And, so, and I interviewed
many of these women,
and they remember
the intense pressure
to get married at the time.
And Wellesley actually had
a section of the yearbook
that listed women
and their engagements
and who they were engaged
to, as well as women
who had gotten married
even before graduating
and had left college, in many
cases, in order to get married.
So, again, that gives
you a sense
of how hard these women had
worked to get their schooling,
but sort of the very limited
field of life prospects
that they were looking
at upon graduation.
But, what I love about this
particular photo is that,
unbeknownst to anybody,
including their colleagues
on the platform,
two of these women,
this is Jacqueline Jenkins,
that was her name at the time,
later on when she married she
would be Jacqueline Jenkins Nye,
the mother of Bill
Nye the Science Guy.
So, you can get a sense
of her intellectual chops,
as well as her friend,
Gwyneth Geminder.
These two young women had
already been secretly selected
and tapped by the U.S. Navy and
they were receiving training
in cryptanalysis,
which was a field
that they would never
have heard of,
that nobody had ever heard of.
They were receiving
weekly instruction
in a locked classroom at the
top of Goucher Hall taught
by Ola Winslow, the English
teacher who, doubtless,
was only maybe a chapter ahead
in the correspondence course
that the U.S. Navy had compiled
to teach them this arcane field
that had been around since
the time of Julius Caesar,
or probably since the time that
human beings learned to write
or communicate at all,
because, you know,
it is sort of human instinct
to send secret communications
to somebody who you have
an urgent message for,
and not have anybody else
be able to listen in.
And, so, this field had been
around really for centuries,
but not so much in the United
States, and nobody really
in the mainstream
had heard of it.
And, so, they were being
taught all of a sudden,
in great secrecy, they
couldn't tell their brothers,
their boyfriends,
their family members,
they couldn't tell their
roommates what they were doing.
They were learning how
to take frequency counts.
They were learning the behavior
of letters in English language,
in the French language.
They were learning how
alphabets could be scrambled,
tables could be constructed
in order
to disguise secret
communications.
And, the reason that was
happening, of course,
was because in December
of 1941, on December 7,
the Pacific fleet had been
attacked at Pearl Harbor.
It was a great shock
and surprise
to the nation, to the world.
It was a surprise attack.
We hadn't seen it coming.
We lost thousands of
young American servicemen.
And, so, we were launched
formally into World War II.
World War II, of
course, had been raging
in Europe for several years.
We knew that we were going to
join the fighting at some point,
but we didn't know
that it was going
to happen abruptly
after December 7.
The next day, of course,
Congress declares war on Japan.
Three days later Germany
declares war on us.
And, all of a sudden,
the U.S. is launched
into what was called total war.
All the young men
signed up to fight.
Japan thought that the attack
at Pearl Harbor would bring us
to our knees, that it
would demoralize us,
that we would allow them to
keep the holdings in the Pacific
that they were conquering,
even as they were bombing
Pearl Harbor, and it had --
it had opposite effect
on the American public.
You know, we rose up in arms.
Every family was determined to
contribute to the war effort.
Every young man wanted to
be in military uniform.
And, all of a sudden, all
the young men were shipping
out to the Pacific,
to islands, you know,
that most Americans never heard
of, to the European theater.
Men were sailing on
convoys going to Europe.
It was just an evacuation
of the men at the --
so, at the same time
that suddenly we're going
to be fighting these battles,
you know, strung out thousands
of miles around the world,
we know that we had no
intelligence agencies.
We have no way of
knowing when there's going
to be another enemy attack,
where the enemy is located,
if we want to attack.
It's very hard to, sort of,
believe this in a day and time
when we have 17 intelligence
agencies in Washington,
D.C. We had none of those when
we were entering World War II,
when we needed intelligence
more than we ever had.
We didn't have a CIA.
We didn't have an NSA.
We didn't have a Director
of National Intelligence.
You know, we have intelligence
agencies now whose job is
to oversee other
intelligence agencies.
We didn't have anything
like that back then.
And, of course, we would form
the OSS very quickly and begin
to build a spy network overseas.
But, the one thing we
could do right away is,
ramp up our ability to intercept
the radio signals, the encrypted
and encoded radio signals
that military commanders,
that politicians, that
diplomats were sending
through the airwaves, you
know, thousands of messages
on a daily basis
announcing their whereabouts,
announcing their plans,
discussing their strategy.
All of this was traveling
through the airwaves,
typically by radio, sometimes by
telegraph, sent by Morse code,
and encrypted the same way that
our incessant Internet messages
that we send every day,
our texts, our e-mails,
our Instagrams, our
Tweets, are often encrypted.
That was what was happening,
is all of these militaries were
strung out all over the world.
So, Admiral Donitz, who was
commanding his U-boat fleet,
commanding each U-boat
individually, sending messages
to those boats every
day, we want to learn how
to snatch those signals
and break them.
We had very small code breaking
operations, the U.S. Army
and the U.S. Navy,
before the war.
So, we need to scale
up, basically.
We need to scale those
operations in a massive way
at exactly the time that
the educated young men
that the military
normally would've turned
to to do this work, were
suddenly unavailable
because they were fighting.
And, so, the U.S.
military makes a decision.
If the educated young men
are unavailable to us,
let's give the women a chance.
Let's open up some
fields of endeavor
to smart, motivated women.
And, so, when I was
doing my work also
at the National Archives
in College Park,
which is a wonderful research
facility, and it's the opposite
of thin beer, I can assure you.
There are thousands and
thousands of records
at the National Archives.
I found this one, in
which some bureaucrat
at the U.S. Navy
got the bright idea,
the Navy had a small
correspondence course going
on for years in which they
would recruit, sort of,
dabblers in cryptology.
They would -- they would
try to bring in hobbyists,
people who might join their
civilian code breaking force
in the 1930's.
So, they had a correspondence
course already,
and they would periodically
produce memos saying
where they were looking for
these kinds of people, these,
you know, particular kinds
of brains they wanted.
And, so, you can
see this memo says,
new source, women's colleges.
So, it's as though the light
bulb went on in somebody's head.
Let's see what the women can do
and if they can do this work.
And, the result of this memo
and the decision, and the fear
in the U.S. Navy that
another attack would happen
like Pearl Harbor, this was
a great intelligence failure.
The Navy knew that.
Careers were ended.
People felt enormous guilt.
They couldn't let this happen.
So, in a moment of desperation
and crisis, let's be inclusive.
Let's bring in the women.
So, as a result of this,
women not only at Goucher,
but at the Seven Sisters
Colleges in the northeast --
on the northeastern seaboard,
the sort of elite women's
colleges that were seen
by the Navy as the counterpart
to the male Ivy league,
senior women, who were
identified by their --
by their deans and
their professors,
often math professors
and astronomy professors,
would identify young women
who were talented at math,
at science, at languages,
but who also showed grit,
who showed persistence,
who showed the willingness
to overcome frustration.
They would secretly tap these
women who would be called in,
to their great surprise, and
would be asked two questions.
Do you like crossword
puzzles and are you engaged
to be married [laughter]?
And if I answered yes to the
first and no to the second,
they would be invited to take
this secret Naval cryptanalytic
training course,
again, in great secrecy,
during the course of
their senior year.
Many of the women
were, in fact, engaged,
because there was enormous
pressure on women to get married
as World War II started
and men were shipping out.
They wanted to have somebody
waiting for them at home
and they wanted to have
somebody to write to.
So, a lot of the
women lied actually.
Although they were engaged,
whatever they were being invited
to do sounded a lot more
interesting than sitting
around waiting to see if
their brothers would be okay,
or their boyfriends
would be okay.
They wanted to join
the war effort.
So, they lied.
They said they weren't engaged.
They took the course and they
came to Washington, D.C. in --
to work as civilians in June
of 1942, at exactly the time
when the Battle of Midway, which
was one of the great sea battles
of all time, it was our first
payback for Pearl Harbor,
showed the U.S. military,
secretly,
because the public didn't
know or shouldn't know,
how important code breaking was
going to be to the war effort.
This was a time when
we did not know
that we were going
to win World War II.
It was not a for
ordained conclusion.
There was enormous concern
that we might not prevail.
You know, the Atlantic Coast
was with besieged by U-boats.
There was enormous fear in the
American public, but the Battle
of Midway was the beginning of
a turning point in the Pacific,
and it turned on brilliant
code breaking that warned us
that the Japanese were
en route ambush us and,
basically, finish us off.
And, instead, we were able
to ambush the Japanese
fleet and win that battle.
And, so, that signaled to
the people who needed to know
that code breaking
was to be important.
And the women started pouring in
from the Seven Sisters Colleges
at exactly the moment when we
knew how important this was
going to be.
But, meanwhile, the U.S.
Army also needs to compete
for educated women, because
the setup at our entry
into the war is that the
UK has lead code breaking
responsibility for the Atlantic
Ocean and the European theater.
So, if you've seen The
Imitation Game, you've heard
about the other great
code breaking success,
which is our breaking
of the enigma cipher,
England's breaking of the
enigma cipher and the ability
to read the German messages that
were controlling the U-boats,
as well as the movements
of the --
of the Air Force and the Army.
So, when we enter the war
we have a vested stake
in the Atlantic as well,
because we're sending our boys
on convoys through the Atlantic,
which is riddled with U-boats.
So, we care, but
we're going to --
we're going to be
the junior partner
in that code breaking efforts.
But, meanwhile, we have lead
and really sole code
breaking responsibility
in the vast, vast Pacific Ocean.
So, the U.S. Navy, which
has just recruited the women
from the Seven Sisters School
and Goucher and other schools,
is going to be working primarily
the Japanese naval fleet code,
which is the major code system
that is being used
by the Japanese Navy.
But, the Japanese army has a
completely different system
and they're now spread out all
over -- all over the Pacific.
They've taken the Philippines.
They've taken islands around
the Pacific, landmasses.
And, again, they are
communicating through signals.
And our U.S. Army
has responsibility
for those signal
systems, and they need
to recruit women as well.
So, they figure -- they make
a different calculation.
They figure, okay,
our competitors
in the U.S. Navy have
the eastern seaboard,
and so we're going to
compete for school teachers.
We're going to turn
to teaching colleges,
which were the other
institutions
that existed to educate women.
So, for example, Dorothy Ramale,
who I interviewed for my book,
was out was at Indiana
State Teachers College
in Indiana, Pennsylvania.
She had grown up in
rural Pennsylvania.
She wanted to be a math teacher.
That was -- that was
an ambitious aspiration
for a woman, because women were
not encouraged to go into math.
They were sometimes
not hired as teachers,
but that's what she wanted
to do, that was her passion.
And she was called in by the
Dean of Women and invited
to take the Army's secret
cryptanalytic training course.
But, even women in teachers'
colleges weren't going
to be enough for the enormous
code breaking operations
that we were going
to have to establish.
So, the Army decided they would
also go after school teachers,
young women who were
actually teaching school.
They were going to be young.
They were going to
be hard-working.
They were going to be single.
They were going to
be well-educated,
and they were going
to be underpaid.
And, so, they were going
to be extremely motivated
to take better paying work
with the war department.
So, the Army's strategy was to,
and I literally found
oral histories
in which commanders
congratulated themselves
for their strategy, they
were thinking that --
they decided to send their
handsomest young army officers
out to lurk in hotels and post
offices, at recruiting stations,
particularly around
the American south.
They were recruiting
women as civilians,
and the bureaucratic rules can
find them at first in Virginia,
North Carolina, South
Carolina, and West Virginia.
The thinking was that
southern women were practically
susceptible to the charms of
a handsome man, and that all
of these hard-working, smart,
young school teachers would be
motivated to come to Washington
to do secret war work, thinking
that they would marry a man
who looked like the
recruiting officer.
And what I love about
that thinking,
about women's motivation, is
that my [inaudible] character,
Dot Braden, who is still
alive and going strong,
represents just sort of how
wrong-headed that strategy was.
Like many young American women,
she was engaged,
but unwillingly so.
Her college boyfriend
had sent her a ring
from training camp
in California.
Women were told not to
upset morale of the troops.
She didn't want to get married.
She didn't want to get
married right out of college.
She didn't particularly
want to marry this guy.
She liked him, but she didn't
envision spending the rest
of her life with him.
Like she wanted an excuse not
to have to get married and go
to his training camp
in California.
And, so, the prospect of war
work in Washington gave her an
out from what would've been her
for ordained sort
of life trajectory.
It gave her an excuse
not to go to California.
She also motivated, because
she was the oldest daughter
in a family of four.
She had two younger brothers who
were already in the U.S. Army,
one of them right
out of high school,
literally the day he
graduated from high school.
So, like all American families,
she had a very personal interest
in the outcome of the war.
The Braden family was typical
in that they were volunteering
everything they could
to the war effort.
People were donating
pots and pans.
They were picking up rubber
bands from the street.
The Braden family tried to
donate their family dog,
Poochie, to train
to become a war dog.
She still has the single spaced
letter that they got back
from the Army War Dog Training
Center saying thank you
for your -- for your
contribution, or for your offer,
unfortunately, we have an age
camp on our -- on our war dogs,
and Poochie was too old.
So, Poochie had to stay home.
But, that's how motivated people
were to join the war effort.
And, so, Dot was also in
her first year of teaching
at Chatham High School, all
the male teachers had left,
many of the female teachers
had left to marry the man.
So, she was teaching English,
French, Latin, physics,
something called hygiene.
She was incredibly burdened
by her teaching load.
She was making $900 a month
teaching school in Chatham.
She came home to her mom
in Lynchburg and she said,
I just can't do that anymore.
Her mom said, well, there
are these recruiters
at the Virginia Hotel
in Lynchburg.
Go see what they want.
So, when Dot walked
through the hotel door,
she didn't care whether that
recruiter was good-looking.
She knew that this was war
work, that it was important,
that it was in Washington, D.C.
Lynchburg was three hours away
from Washington, D.C.
She had never been there.
She grew up during
the depression.
People didn't travel.
She had never seen the big city.
This was an opportunity
to join the war effort,
to try to help her brothers,
and to make $1660 working
for the war department,
which was almost twice what
she would make it as a teacher.
So, like thousands of other
southern school teachers,
Dot got on the train one
morning and came to Washington,
D.C. and found herself in Union
Station with a little bit amount
of money in her pocketbook and
no idea what she had signed
up to do, because
this recruiting
of school teachers were
taking place in public.
They couldn't even tell the
women what they had signed
up for.
She took a cab to Arlington,
Virginia, and she found herself
at what had, up until
recently, been a junior college.
And junior colleges
were a thing back then.
They were a way to give
women some education
without giving them
too much education.
So, they basically
amounted to two years
of high school and two years.
The women could get
some English, some math,
maybe some French,
some piano, and typing,
some horseback riding.
You know, the kinds of things
that would prepare
them for adulthood.
So, the Army needed
a big secure,
off the beaten path compound
for its code breaking effort.
So, it kicked the girls out.
It requisitioned Arlington Hall.
It built enormous
temporary buildings
where the writing pads had been.
And it routed these
southern school teachers
into these massive, hot,
temporary buildings.
The first day in Washington, Dot
had no idea what she was signing
up to do, but she had
to sign a loyalty oath
to the U.S. government, she had
to sign a secrecy oath agreeing
that she would never
talk about it.
It was wartime.
The penalty for revealing
top-secret work was death,
and so knew that
whatever she was going
to be doing she would be shot
if she told anybody about it.
So, that was her
welcome to Washington.
All of the women who came to
do this work would be told
that if anybody asked
them what they were doing
in these compounds they were to
say that they were secretaries,
that they sharpened pencils,
they emptied wastebaskets,
they did unimportant work.
Some said that they
sat on the laps
of their commanding officers.
Everybody believed that,
because they were women.
The work they were
doing had to be trivial.
And, so, in that -- in that way
they were the ideal intelligence
officers of the time,
because people just assumed
that whatever they were
doing inside these top-secret
compounds it couldn't be really
important to the war effort.
But, instead, Dot
joined classrooms
where school teachers were very
hastily instructed, in this case
in the geography of Asia.
These are women who would
be receiving the messages
that we intercepted
from the Pacific.
We would encrypt them
with own encryption,
send them to Arlington Hall.
We would -- we would strip
out the American encryption
and then school teachers,
like Dot,
would get started
on the messages.
This is the room that
Dot would've worked in.
You can see all of these
young women working at tables.
She still has a hard
time believing
that she had joined
what would be the third
of the three most important
code breaking triumphs
of World War II.
So, one of them was
the Battle of Midway.
One of them was breaking
of the enigma cipher.
But, the third, which
doesn't get as much attention
because it's not like a
single dramatic moment,
was our relentless shipping --
sinking of the ships that were
supplying the Japanese army all
around the Pacific.
The Japanese were on
islands, for the most part.
they had to be regularly
supplied with water, with food,
with fuel, with medicine,
with spare airplane parts,
with reinforcement troops, all
of that was brought by ship.
Those ships were sending
messages every day saying
where they were coming from,
where they were going to.
It was a complicated
system called an enciphered
code system.
A word like [inaudible] for
supply ship would be rendered
as a four-digit code group.
Another four digits
would be added to that
to change the numbers, that was
an early form of encryption,
and that would be sent by Morse
code through the airwaves.
We would snatch that
out of the air.
The school teachers would start
stripping out that encryption,
stripping out the
extraneous numbers,
to get down to the code
group, and then trying
to figure out what they meant.
Because they did their work
so well, because they did it
so rapidly, Dot remembers
running to get the messages
to the next stage, we were able
to sink thousands
of supply ships.
The information in the
messages would be sent
to American submarine
commanders, who would be waiting
when the supply ships appeared.
They were relentlessly sunk.
And, the result of that,
was that most Japanese
army deaths were the result
of starvation and disease.
That's how well the school
teachers did their job.
Dot remembers that she would
get the message along as far
as she could, and
she would take it
to a woman called
the overlapper.
And she was very nervous
about speaking that word,
because the women
were told never
to even utter certain words
on the streets of Washington.
Overlap was a term of
art, and if they spoke it
on the street maybe somebody
from the access would overhear.
So, when I did my interview
with her, or my many interviews
with her, she had never even
used the word overlapper,
and she felt uneasy
about saying it even now.
But, what she remembered,
and this is --
this is one my favorite
parts of the story,
is that the overlapper
was a woman named Miriam,
and she was from New York
City, because there were women
who were recruited from
northern colleges as well.
And Dot remembers Miriam
as being the most condescending
northerner she had ever met.
And I'm from the same part
of Virginia that Dot is,
so I somewhat identified
with this part
of the story, I have to admit.
And she recalled that Miriam
would make fun of her accent,
would make fun of
her southern accent.
And it's true that at
Arlington Hall, you know,
even as American GI's were
going all over the world
at great peril and
risk to their lives,
they were seeing the South
Pacific, they were seeing Paris,
these women were
coming together,
they were seeing Washington,
and they were meeting women
from other parts of the country.
So, but they were also
having to function with them
in a workplace, and it was
incredibly important work,
but it was also a government
workplace, and Miriam got
on Dot's nerves because
the women clashed.
They were from different
parts of the country.
The northerners tended
to see the southern women
as being less well-educated.
There were also men working
at the code breaking facility
who were too old
for the fighting,
so there were many distinguished
men from publishing circles
in New York City who
came down to work
in the code breaking
operation as well,
and one of them referred to the
southern women as the jewels.
And the reason he called
them that was because he felt
so many southern
women were named Opel
or Pearl or Ruby or Emerald.
And, I have to admit, when
I went through the rosters
at the National Archives, there
were a lot of women named Ruby
and Emerald and Pearl, and
there were also some Jewels.
And one of the women that I
interviewed for this book,
Jewel S. Mocker [assumed
spelling] in South Carolina,
she was a graduate of Winthrop
College in South Carolina.
She was a high school
band director
when she was recruited
to do this work.
And musical talent
is also a marker
for code breaking ability,
because it involves the
ability to follow patterns.
So, I have to -- I have to grant
that there were a fair amount
of southern women who
had jewel-like names.
I love this photo, because the
woman that you see laughing
down at her work sitting
next to dead plant,
she had been recruited
as an English major
out of Russell Sage
College outside of New York.
And she, working with a West
Virginia school teacher named
Wilma Berryman, those two women
broke a separate code system
that appended every
Japanese army message.
It was the address.
It was the address of
where it was coming to
and where it was destined
for, the person sending it,
the rank of the person sending
it, the person receiving it,
the rank of that
person, and a vast amount
of useful information for our
military to have because we want
to know where the Japanese
are, where they're going to,
who they're communicating with.
If a flurry of messages
is going to new location,
maybe something is
being planned.
So, thanks to their breaking
of that particular
message system we were able
to provide the Pentagon every
day with something called order
of battle, that showed where
the Japanese army was located
and where messages, new
messages, were being sent to.
So, that was incredibly
important intelligence.
These women were
generating intelligence,
that the Pentagon was actually
breathing down their neck to get
that order of battle
report every day.
Just to give you a
sense of how many code
and cipher systems were
in play during the war,
the Japanese diplomats, who
were stationed in Europe,
in all the occupied countries,
all the access countries,
they were communicating back
with Tokyo using a completely
different cipher system.
It was a machine that scrambled
Romanized Japanese into,
you know, unintelligible
gibberish.
We had broken that machine
system before the war thanks
to a woman named
Genevieve Grotjan.
We were reading all of those
diplomatic communications.
One of the most important
bits of intelligence we got
from the Japanese
diplomats about Europe was
when they were invited
to tour the coast
of France before D-day.
They dutifully reported back
to Tokyo on where the coast
of France was well
fortified and where it wasn't.
So, we knew that when we were
planning the Allied landing
that Normandy would be
a better place to land
than other parts of
the French coast.
So, that's the kind of
information that we were getting
from these code breaking
operations.
Again, this just gives you a
sense of the number of women
who were doing this work.
There was also an
African-American code breaking
unit at Arlington Hall.
The U.S. Army was segregated
during World War II.
So, the code breaking operation
was segregated as well.
This was a secret unit.
A lot of the white workers
didn't even know about it.
But, this group of very
well-educated, very dedicated,
probably former school teachers,
who had attained their education
in a -- in a segregated
U.S. education system,
were lending their talents to
breaking the codes and ciphers
of the private sector.
So, just as banks and
companies today encrypt all
of their financial
communication when they send it
over the Internet, so, too,
were they doing that back then.
This unit was reading the
codes and ciphers of banks
and companies to see who was
doing business with Hitler,
who was doing business
with Japanese companies
like Mitsubishi,
because, of course,
they weren't supposed
to be doing that.
So, this was very
important work,
and this was a very unsung unit.
They were also doing early
cipher security, looking for --
to make sure that
our encrypted traffic
that we were sending
was more secure
than the code systems
that we were reading.
They were also planning
deception programs,
creating something
called dummy traffic,
that would persuade the enemy,
just because of the
signals we were sending,
would persuade the enemy
that we had troops stationed
where none existed.
And, again, before
the D-Day landings,
this dummy traffic
persuaded the Germans
that we had Allied troops
ready to invade Calais.
So, they thought the
main landing was going
to come in Calais.
So, meanwhile, during World War
II, this is the tipping point,
this is the first really major
experiment with admitting women
into the military, and the
decision was made in 1942
to admit women into the Army,
and also to admit
women into the Navy.
It was a hard-fought battle.
Many of the deans and professors
at the women colleges
really pressed the Navy
to admit young women.
They saw this as an
opportunity, again,
to expand opportunities
for their graduates.
So, the women who came to
Washington, you saw them
in those frilly dresses at the
beginning, they ultimately --
the Navy wanted its female
code breakers to be --
to be subject to
military discipline
and the military hierarchy.
So, they were trained to
become naval officers.
So, you can see them here.
Actually, they're
crossing Nebraska Avenue.
The Navy also needed a lot more
space than it had downtown,
so it commandeered
Mount Vernon Seminary,
which was on Nebraska
Avenue where Department
of Homeland Security is now.
Kicked those girls out.
The girls had to take classes
at Garfinkel's Department Store
while they were finding a place
to study, and they set up a
massive code breaking operation.
The women were housed
in barracks near
American University.
You can see them
crossing the street.
So, this was a great moment
for women to join the military.
It was also a moment when women,
who had not had the benefit
of a college education,
could enlist, you know,
could enlist as ordinary seamen.
And when they took
their aptitude tests,
if they tested high for ability,
you know, and for the sort
of the right kind of
intellectual skills like math
and languages, they
would be secretly routed
into the code breaking
operation.
So, again, this was a great
coming together of women
from all over the country,
women from Colorado.
The Navy was looking for
librarians, people who knew how
to keep great records.
So, women came from Colorado,
from California, from Oklahoma.
They got on troop trains.
They traveled for days.
They went to boot camp
and officer training camp,
and they came together,
thousands of women
working at these compounds.
One of my favorite anecdotes
about the coming together
of these women, one of the women
I interviewed for this book,
Jane Case, actually came
from a very affluent
family in New York City.
She grew up in Auburn, New York
and then on the upper east side
of New York City, a very --
a very sort of debutante kind
of society that she was kind of
expecting to have to be part of.
When the -- when the
war started she, again,
wanted to do anything she could.
She desperately wanted to
enlist in the U.S. Navy.
Her parents didn't want her to.
There was a lot of stigma
at first associated
with these women.
They were considered
to be bad women.
There were whisper
campaigns against them.
The thinking was, that they
were being put into the military
to service the man sexually.
And, so, some parents didn't
want their daughters joining up,
but Jane was determined.
So, she took the subway
down to Wall Street
where there was a naval
recruiting station.
She expected that she would
go in with an officer,
as an officer because she came
from such an upper-class family,
and she knew she'd have
to pass an eye exam.
So, she had -- and she
was very, very nearsighted
and she had memorized the
eyechart in order to make it
through the eye exams.
She slipped her spectacles
in her pocket.
And she did make it through the
eye exam, but she didn't know
that there were going to be a
lot of other medical stations,
including a gynecological
exam, which was a shock
for a lot of the women.
But, there was also
a physical exam.
And men, at the time,
were forced to undergo a group
naked physical to join the Navy.
The Navy was trying to
figure out whether, you know,
it should sort of do the
same things for women
that it was doing for man.
So, the women had a naked
group physical as well,
and Jane still remembers the
shock of being told to disrobe,
and then she remembers
that a petty officer drew the
number nine between her breasts
and said, okay, go stand
between eight and 10,
and never had never seen another
woman without her clothes on,
and because she was so
nearsighted, she not only had
to look, she had to
really peer in order to --
in order to figure out where
she was supposed to stand.
So, she remembers that
fondly as sort of, you know,
you're in the Navy now.
And this was -- this was -- this
was something quite different
than the debutante society
she had been raised to.
And when she -- and she also
found that, she had gone
to music school after
graduating from high school,
the Navy didn't consider
that to be equivalent
of two years of college.
So, she went in as
an ordinary seaman.
She went in as an
enlisted woman,
and because of her ability with
math, her dad was a physicist,
and because of her
chops, she was routed
into the code breaking operation
as well, and she loved it.
Her first roommate
was from the Midwest
and her dad was an undertaker
and gave his daughter a music
box in the shape of a casket.
And, so, that was Jane's
introduction to sort
of other American
decorating schemes
that she had not grown up with.
So, the Navy women worked
at this huge compound.
I found these photographs in
the National Archives just kind
of swimming around in files.
As you can see, I had to
get them declassified,
but they're wonderful
photos of the interior
of the Navy code breaking unit.
The women were working the
Japanese naval fleet code.
You can see on the table massive
stacks of Japanese messages.
Jane remembered, we could
tell what was happening
in the Pacific because the
stack would get larger.
They had to make decisions about
which messages were important.
They had to push them along
as fast as they could.
They, too, had to strip
out numerical encipherment
called additives in order to get
down to the code groups.
They were under incredible
pressure.
They knew that their
brothers were in the Pacific.
They were sometimes breaking
messages that told the location
and the -- and the whereabouts
and the fate of their brothers'
and their boyfriends' ships.
They knew the stakes.
I found memos in the
National Archives
in which their officers
would say,
you all recovered 2000
additives last month.
We need more this month.
You know, we're planning to
push back across the Pacific.
We want to retake
the Philippines.
This work is incredibly
important.
We need to know where
the enemy is.
And, so, we need you all
to work harder and faster.
And I would see memos
congratulating them,
for not only meeting their
quota, but for exceeding it.
So, this will show you, this
is one of the worksheets.
The Japanese naval fleet code
was a five-digit enciphered
code system.
I just love these worksheets.
Again, they're swimming in
files at the National Archives,
but they give you a sense of the
brain work that the women had
to do in order to
recover these additives.
I also love this table.
Again, it shows you how
many different code systems
there were.
This was a completely
different system.
It was a lesser system
that the Japanese Navy,
sort of an ad hoc system, they
set up, completely different.
It was letters, not numbers.
There was a group of women from
Wellesley who were assigned
to work the interisland cipher.
It had a key that changed
every month, and they had
to break back into the
-- into the system.
They had to determine the new
key that was being used to sort
of control the system
every month.
And they got so good at that,
and I found records talking
about how good they were at
that, but they could sort
of work really hard for five
days and then go a little bit
on autopilot for the
rest of the month.
And you remember, that these
women were living unchaperoned
for the first time in
their lives in Washington,
D.C. There was a lot of alcohol
in Washington during
World War II.
And, if the women
were naval officers,
they could live in group houses.
They didn't have to
live in barracks.
So, they could have parties.
And the Wellesley
women had big blowouts.
And I found an oral history
of their commanding officer,
who very much admired
their intelligence,
but also admired their
partying spirits.
He would remember that
one of the mathematicians
in particular, a math major
from Wellesley would come to him
and ask, when is she going
to have her next big party?
And he would look at the wall
map and he would say, okay,
the key is going to change
at X day of the month,
you can have your party
two weeks before that,
because then you can
recover from your hangovers
for two weeks before you have
to really apply your intellect.
But, again, to give you
a sense of the stakes,
in April of 1942 we received
messages in the Pacific saying
that Admiral Yamamoto,
who commanded the Japanese naval
fleet, and was the mastermind
of Pearl Harbor, was going to
be making an inspection tour
of the Solomon Islands.
The interisland cipher was part
of this set of communications.
Men in the Pacific,
American men in the Pacific,
got busy on the naval
fleet code messages.
These women got busy on
the interisland cipher.
They put together his exact
itinerary down to the minute
so that we were able to send
planes up and shoot his plane
out of the air and
basically make the decision
to assassinate an
enemy commander.
And the women remembered
that cheering went
up in the naval code breaking
compound when they knew
that the admiral's plane
had been shot down.
Of course, the American public
and the Japanese could not know
that it happened as a result
of code breaking,
but the women knew.
And it's important, I think,
to point out that they felt
great satisfaction at the time
when they knew that their
work had actually contributed
to the sinking of a convoy
or a fleet or to the downing
of an important airplane.
It was, you know, it was war.
We wanted to win it.
They knew that lives
were at stake, again,
of their brothers
and boyfriends.
They knew that America was at
stake and freedom was at stake.
So, they -- you know, they
wanted to win and they wanted
to do what had to be done.
Later on in their
lives they would come
to have more complex
feelings about the, you know,
lethal work that
they were part of,
but at the time there
were no second thoughts.
So, just to quickly point out,
we eventually really became the
senior partner in the breaking
of the enigma cipher that
Admiral Donitz was using
to command his U-boats.
The Germans suspected that we
were reading their code system.
They changed the enigma machine
that was being used
by the U-boats.
They added an extra rotor that
scrambled the messages even more
than they had been
scrambled before.
And, so, the American industrial
resources had to get involved
to build these giant machines
that could handle a
four-rotor enigma machine.
The old one had been three
rotors, and now we needed sort
of more heavy-duty,
faster machines.
And, so, the Americans designed
and built these machines
that were secretly
transported, again,
to the naval code
breaking compound.
For me, one of the most
moving, and, ultimately,
it was really women who were
working the German enigma
cipher system.
It involved a lot of math.
It involved designing early
computer menus in order
to break into those messages.
And one of the most moving
chapters to me of the book was
when the women join the
midnight watch on the --
on the night of June 6,
early morning June 5,
and then going into June 6.
They knew that the D-Day
landings were going to happen.
They didn't know when
they were going to happen.
It was a full moon.
They assumed that was not ideal
for a secret Allied landing,
so they thought it wasn't
going to happened on the 6th.
But, they remember
that at about 1:30
in the morning our time they
started getting messages.
You know, the machines
started spinning.
The German's started chattering.
And it was -- they
were experiencing --
these women were
experiencing the D-Day landings
from the point of
view of the Germans.
And the first messages were
basically German, you know,
officers saying -- seeing
thousands and thousands
of Allied ships on the
horizon saying, oh my God,
the landing is happening and
it's happening in Normandy.
And, so, the women remembered
all that night just working
as fast as they could to
break the German messages.
So, they were in
the unique position
of experiencing the D-Day
landing from the point of view
of the Germans, who
were communicating
about what was going on.
So, they knew the
landings were happening.
They knew that they had brothers
and boyfriends and fiances
that were making the landing.
They didn't know
how it was going.
You know, they couldn't tell
from the German messages
everything
about the D-Day invasion.
So, they were really
overwhelmed by the enormity
of what they were part of.
And, at the end of their --
of their midnight shift
they remember taking the bus
to National Cathedral and then
going into Saint Albans Chapel,
which was open 24 seven
during World War II,
and praying because
they didn't know,
you know, what the outcome was.
They didn't know how
many lives had been lost.
And a number of them had,
in fact, lost their fiances
in the invasion and they
just didn't know that yet,
because they hadn't
got a telegraph.
These are some photos
of my central character.
You can see Dot Braden
behind the pole.
At the same time, again,
that they were doing this
incredibly serious, urgent,
stressful work, they were having
a good time in Washington.
They were writing lots of men.
My central character was
actually writing half a
dozen men.
She was, in some ways, more
reluctant to confess that to me
than she was to talk about
her secret code breaking work.
She disentangle herself
from her engagement,
and ultimately married one of
the men that she was writing to.
Had a very happy marriage.
She became best friends with
a school teacher from Bourbon,
Mississippi, Ruth Weston,
an incredible mathematician,
who would go on to work for
the NSA as a mathematician.
The women remained best friends
for the rest of their lives.
You can see them there
with their husbands.
They remained such
close friends.
After the war they could
never talk to each other
about their code breaking work.
They didn't even know
that they were part
of the same code breaking effort
to break the supply ships.
They knew they both worked
in the same compound,
but they were terrified
of talking
about their work either
before or after the war.
All of these women were
told at the end of the war,
thanks very much
for your efforts.
You saved thousands of lives.
You shorten the war
by at least a year.
Now, never tell anybody
what you did.
And, so, they went into
later life never talking
about this work.
Dot's brothers both
survived the war.
They -- both of her
brothers would take jobs
that involved top-secret
security clearances.
They would get together and brag
about their secret
security clearances.
Dot could never tell them
that she also had a
top-secret security clearance.
So, that's the kind of thing
that the women had to put
up with for decades and decades
for the rest of their lives.
But, they remained so close that
their children, for a long time,
thought they were cousins.
Their children thought they
were related to each other,
because they knew that their --
that these two women
shared a great friendship,
as well as a secret, some secret
about what they had
done during the war.
This is a group of
Naval enlisted women
who also remained great
friends after the war was over.
Only one of them is
still alive, Ruth Mirsky,
who you can see in
the striped shirt.
And her e-mail, when
she communicates
with me, it's Ruth the Wave.
So, you know, at
95 she's on e-mail
because they were code girls
then and they're code girls now.
And this work, although
they couldn't talk about it
for 75 years, remained so
important to them that would,
you know, that she chose
that as her e-mail address.
And I just wanted to end
with a couple of quick videos
that give you a sense of the
women talking about their work,
talking about what was important
to them, and remembering,
you know, some of their
most memorable experiences.
So, this is Dot.
>> With my two suitcases, my
umbrella, and my raincoat,
I went down to the train.
Now, my uncle had to
take me down there.
No car. And my mother and her
sister were standing there
crying when I got on the train.
I was very secure
that everything was
going to be just fine.
Washington would receive
me with open arms.
>> Liza Mundy: And, of
course, the message she got
in Washington was
that she would be shot
if she told anybody
what she was doing.
So, the next woman, Anne
Seeley, was recruited
out of Smith College in 1942,
and she would work the
Japanese naval fleet code.
>> An additive is, obviously,
something that you add,
but what do you add it to.
You add it to a five-digit
code group.
And the code group has a
meaning, which is either a word
or a phrase or a sentence
or a Roman letter.
Because we're dealing
in Japanese now [inaudible] make
much use of the Roman letters.
But, they often did
to spell names.
>> Liza Mundy: Right.
>> People like [inaudible].
>> Liza Mundy: So, her
memory was so sharp.
She had never talked about this
in 75 years, and she remembered
that the Japanese would have
to have a different code group
for every letter of
the name Roosevelt,
because they might not have,
you know, an actual character
that stood for Roosevelt.
So, her memory was so sharp
she actually showed me the math
that she had to do in order
to recover the additives.
She got a little irritated
when I seemed a little
slow on the uptake.
So, because I was saying,
well, they had added it,
so did you subtract or add?
And she said, well, we would
zeroize [phonetic] and add.
I mean, you know,
how hard is that?
So, I just loved how precise
her memory was of this work
that she had never
told anybody about.
The next woman, Betty Bemis
Robards, worked those --
helped build those machines that
broke the German enigma cipher,
and then remembers basically
the thanks that they got
for the great work
that they did.
>> We broke the code in August
1943, and everybody says,
what did they tell you?
I said, nothing.
All that Commander Meater
[assumed spelling] announced
at supper one night,
good job, girls.
You did good.
And that's all he said.
>> Liza Mundy: And the
last woman, Dorothy Ramale,
you saw her photo earlier in the
presentation, she was recruited
out of Indiana State
Teachers College,
and she remembers why it was
so important to the women
to do this work when
they were recruited.
>> A bus came, and it was at
two o'clock in the morning
that the Army sent a bus to
get these, oh, I don't know,
it seemed to me it was
all the men, you know,
that there were no men left
in the college at that time
because they all had to
go, I think, to Pittsburgh.
You see, since I was
taking mathematics,
[inaudible] I was one of
maybe two girls that were
in the classes, you see.
So, I knew so many
of the fellows
that were going on that bus.
I'll never forget.
>> Liza Mundy: So, Dorothy
Ramale was such a --
was such a successful
code breaker
that the U.S. Navy actually
stole her from the U.S. Army.
She was that good.
And what I love about her is
that she became a math
teacher after the war.
She never told anybody
what she did.
She would end up teaching
at the Public Middle School
in Arlington, Virginia, that my
own children would ultimately
attend, Swanson, and then
Yorktown High School.
And I just love the thought
of these middle school kids
taking Miss Ramale's algebra one
class and having no idea
that this sweet woman,
who people remember as an
incredible math teacher,
had been such a badass code
breaker during World War II.
And, of course, she never
talked about it, you know,
until I interviewed her.
And she's also an
example of the fact
that these women walked among
us, you know, for decades
and decades, and in many
cases, still walk among us.
They never expected
credit for what they did.
In most cases, they never got
any credit for what they did.
They took the secret
to their graves.
I felt very fortunate,
ultimately,
to be able to find 20
women, living women,
who could talk about their work.
You see how excellent
their memories were.
And to be able to, you know,
to try and get them some credit
for the incredible
contribution that they made
to winning the war, and to
American freedom and democracy.
I mean, that's not
an overstatement.
And, again, never
expecting credit.
One of the -- I will say that
by the time I was interviewing
them, they knew that they
had been left out of history.
They knew that books
that were written
about Pacific code breaking
and Atlantic code breaking
during the '90s, you know,
had pretty much not
told their story,
because the women had been so
good about not speaking up.
And one of the women I
interviewed in an emergency room
in Atlanta, because she had
broken her wrist the night
before, I learned that
emergency rooms are good places
to interview, because you
have to wait a long time
and they can't -- the
person can't go anywhere.
But, she said that, you know,
I just hope that
I live long enough
to see the book published, and
I am happy to say that she did.
So, thank you so
much for listening.
It's been a great honor to work
with the Library of Congress
and trying to tell the story.
[ Applause ]
And I think we have time
for a few questions.
>> Karen Lloyd: I was
going to do [inaudible].
>> Liza Mundy: Oh.
>> Karen Lloyd: Thank
you, Liza, for bringing
to light the stories of
these incredible women
and the contributions they
made to the course of war,
technology, code breaking,
and cyber security.
Because of your work
using primary sources,
like those found at the
Veterans' History Project,
stories like these
cannot be ignored.
They will forever be included
in the annals of history.
When we first started
planning this book talk,
we were thinking how great
it would be to have some
of those code girls
here with us today,
but because they are generally
in their 90's and a bit frail,
we thought, well, let's
do the next best thing.
And Liza helped us reach out
to those families and get some
of those collections
that we didn't have
in our archives here.
And in February we received
a package containing an oral
history interview, photographs,
and a memoir that was written
by Elizabeth McClure Bennett.
And her son, George Bennett,
Junior, when he found
out what we were doing,
rallied his family
to collect these items and
send them to us right away.
In one of the e-mails he
sent to our staff he wrote,
my mother is still alive, but
her health has been very poor
over the last several years.
Our family is very
grateful to Liza Mundy
for her great book featuring
the code girls, and to you
and the Veterans' History
Project for preserving the story
of these remarkable women.
I'm very sad to report that Mrs.
Bennett passed away on the 16th
of March at the ripe
old age of 96.
I would suggest to you,
she lived a good life.
I understand that her family
is watching live on YouTube,
and her son, Doug, flew
in from Indianapolis
to be with us today.
So, thank you, Doug.
And --
[ Applause ]
I want -- I want them to
understand how grateful
that we are to make sure that
their mom's story is going
to live on in perpetuity
here at the library.
And, so, again, thank you
for that round of applause
for Doug and his family.
And in closing, if you're like
the Bennetts and have a veteran
in your life, living or
deceased, no matter the gender,
branch, service, or
military assignment,
please consider donating
their story
to the Veterans'
History Project.
We've got a table set up outside
where you can get our field kit.
You can go up our
website, loc.gov/vets
and hear some amazing stories,
and this way you can preserve,
you can ensure that loved
one's story will be preserved
and not lost or forgotten.
So, again, thank you
for joining us today.
And now we have some
time for questions for --
with you and with Liza.
So, without further ado.
>> Liza Mundy: Sure.
>> Did any of the
women demand proof
that it was now unclassified
and -- oh, sorry.
Did any of the women
demand proof
that it was now unclassified and
that they could talk about it?
Or, did they just believe you?
>> Liza Mundy: It did, in
some cases, take persuasion.
It took me about a half
an hour to persuade Dot
that she wouldn't be put in
prison if she -- if she spoke.
And I told her that if she was,
it would probably a
nice prison at her age.
And, so, in some cases
it did take some coaxing.
And I will say, that they had
been released from their oath
of secrecy back in the 1990's,
but nobody had tracked
them down and told them.
So, they were free to speak.
>> Yes, your pictures of the
crossing on Wisconsin Avenue,
a number of years ago I
had an opportunity to look
at some photographs in the
[inaudible] collection.
And the first walk, don't
walk pedestrian signals were
installed in the District
of Columbia at that site.
So, I guess they were
concerned about the safety
of these women [laughter].
>> Liza Mundy: Yes, yes,
and they were also --
yeah, there were also some
neighbors who complained
about noise and singing,
as well as necking
in the woods, so, yeah.
>> But, in 1965 I was sent by
the Army to Fort Meade and NSA
for an eight-week training
in the cryptography,
and six of us were sent.
We walked into the
training unit that day
and we were totally
surrounded by women.
And I'm wondering if
NSA is like that today,
and if there are studies
if women are better wired
for this type of work.
>> Liza Mundy: Well,
I don't know,
I don't know when that was.
But, I should've said that
many of these women did stay
on with the work after the war.
We didn't roll up our code
breaking after World War II,
because the Cold War started.
So, we would be breaking East
German, Russian, Chinese,
communist code systems, and
many of the women did stay
with the work and went to
work, ultimately, for the NSA.
So, you saw Ann Caracristi
laughing down at her dead plant,
she would rise to become the
first female deputy director
of NSA, and many of
the first super grades
at NSA were women
coming out of the war.
So, there was an
important cohort of women
who helped establish
that agency.
>> I was curious, how does
the Navy steal someone
from the Army?
And, also, is that
correspondence course
in code breaking now public?
>> Liza Mundy: Yes, so,
the correspondence
courses can be found
at the National Archives.
I mean, they still
exist as paper records.
I'm sure there is an
updated modern version of it,
but you can find
the ones from 1942.
I did study them when
I was trying to sort
of understand how it worked.
And, the way that the Navy
stole her from the Army was,
they paid a little bit more
money, because she had a --
she had a college degree, so she
knew she could go into the Navy
as an officer and she could
get an officer's allowance.
It wasn't that the
salary was more,
but she could get an officer's
allowance for housing,
and that bit more money, $50
a month or whatever it was,
enabled her to buy a car.
The other -- her
other goal in life was
to see all the continents in the
-- in the world, which she did.
But, she was -- with her car
she was able, after the war,
to drive to the west coast,
and that was really
thrilling for her.
So, it was money.
>> Hi. I just have
a quick question.
When an individual was given
the code to break down,
did they already -- were they
working like from a template?
So, they'd say, okay, if
this is an X it means B?
If this is a four it means a Z?
Or, were they literally
breaking down the code itself?
>> Liza Mundy: They were
breaking the message.
So, they would get the message
and they would see the message,
but they were -- they were,
you know, some of the --
again, some of the
systems were numerical
and they had to do math.
Some of them were, they
would be looking at letters.
There was a lot of variation
and they had to understand
that particular system
and break it in real time.
So, the training courses
that they had gotten
at their colleges often
really had nothing to do
with the actual code
systems that they --
that they had to work on.
They had to really learn it
on the job, because there was
so much innovation and change
taking place during the war.
>> Were there any women that
you wanted to interview,
or that you wish you
could have interviewed,
but had already passed on?
>> Liza Mundy: Oh yes, oh yes.
And that's why I was so
grateful for the oral histories
and collections at the
Library of Congress.
And it was frustrating, because
sometimes the oral history
interviewer wouldn't
ask the question
that I would've liked
to have known.
And one of the women
talked about the experience
of losing her husband
in the D-Day landing.
He was a glider pilot.
And it was clearly something
that she wanted to talk about,
and she couldn't even
go to his funeral
because she was working those
big machines and they had
to continue after
the D-Day landing,
because of course we were --
we were going to be chasing
the Germans through Europe
with the Battle of the Bulge.
It was very important.
They wouldn't release the
women from their stations,
so she couldn't even go to
her own husband's funeral.
And I felt like that interviewer
was a little bit uncomfortable
talking to her about that
loss, because she said really
that she loved him for
the rest of her life.
And, so, there were moments
when I wish that, obviously,
I could've talked to the women
in person, but I was so grateful
for the oral history
collections.
>> Did you ever hear back
from the editor who said
that it was thin beer?
>> Liza Mundy: No,
but I hope he's --
I hope he's regretting
those words.
I actually found
them very motivating.
And, so, if any high school
students are listening,
or college students,
and if a teacher says
to you, you can't do that.
Or, you know, or if there's a
young woman out there who says,
you know, you shouldn't go into
STEM, you know, don't listen
to them and use it
as a motivation,
because I certainly -- I got up
every morning thinking, again,
okay, I'll show you thin beer.
So, the book has been optioned,
and I'm told that, you know,
there a lot of stages
that it has to go through.
But, there is, you know, thanks,
Hidden Figures has really been
wonderful for women's stories,
for convincing publishers,
and also, I think, you know,
studios that there is an
appetite for women's stories.
We have people like Reese
Witherspoon, you know,
talking about the importance
of women fronted narratives.
So, I'm optimistic.
I mean, it would be --
it would be great to see.
>> Hi, I was just kind of
curious about your process.
Like, did you find all the info
before or did you have some kind
of like narrative
that it fit into?
>> Liza Mundy: That is
such a great question.
So, normally I would've
spent a lot
of time reading books
about code breaking.
I would've spent a lot of
time in the paper records
to really educate myself,
and then I would've gone
to the women when I had a
really thorough grounding.
But, because of my actuarial
deadline, because the women were
in their mid-90's, I wanted
to interview them first.
And, so, I was -- while I
would be talking to them,
I would be wondering
if I would be able
to find an actual printed record
that would substantiate
their memories,
and I didn't know whether
it would be out there.
And, again, I was amazed
at how much there was
in the National Archives
and the Library of Congress
that enabled me to substantiate.
You saw Anne Seeley.
She remembered something
called a [inaudible] message,
which was a noon
position message.
They would look for that.
The Japanese naval captains
would send a message saying
where they were going to
be at noon the next day,
which is the best possible
piece of information
for an American submarine
commander to have.
And when I finally got
to the National Archives,
I found references
to [inaudible] messages
all over the place.
It was remarkable how
accurate their memories were.
So, that's a great question.
I had to -- I had
to do it backwards.
>> Are there lists of people
who worked at those groups?
I know a number of people
probably wonder and --
>> Liza Mundy: Yeah.
>> And would like to look
up -- look up a name or so.
>> Liza Mundy: That is
such a great question.
There aren't good -- there's
not a single good roster.
I wish that NSA had
the resources,
or The Cryptologic
Museum had the resources.
If they had more funding,
I'm sure they would try
to put together a roster.
There are just scrambled files,
in which I might see some
of the women who
came down in 1942,
where they were living
and, but there's no
like one central place where
you could look at the names.
But, if there's somebody
in your family,
or even somebody you know who
might have done this work,
or who said she was a
secretary during the war,
that information, those
personnel records are public,
and I have a website,
www.lizamundy.com.
I have a tab called resources
for code breakers and families.
You can request anybody's
wartime personnel record
and you can find out.
If it says they were a
cryptographer or a cryptologist,
then that means they
did this work.
And you can often get
their background reports,
their college transcripts.
It's kind of remarkable,
actually,
what's available,
and it's not hard.
>> What was the seed or the idea
that drew you to
write this story?
>> Liza Mundy: So, all --
many of our federal agencies
have wonderful history offices
and historians that generate
and record the history
of their agency.
So, the NSA knew that its
origin story included these
wartime women.
And, just as NASA knew that
its origins story included the
African-American
women mathematicians
of Hidden Figures, so I
read a declassified history
of a small code breaking
project during the war
that had been written
by an NSA historian.
It was out on the Internet,
classified at one point
that had been declassified,
and it mentioned,
this was the Russian
code breaking,
our small project during the
war to break Russian messages.
And it mentioned that a
lot of the people working
that project were women,
a lot of them were former
school teachers from the south,
and that seemed really
intriguing.
So, I made an appointment
to speak
with an NSA historian named
Betsy Smoot [assumed spelling],
who was extremely
helpful to me, and a --
and a curator at the Cryptologic
Museum, which is attached
to an MSA at Fort
Meade, two women,
and it was as though they
had been waiting for somebody
to come along who was
interested in this story.
And they sat with me for two
hours and they explained,
you know, the larger
story that was --
that was the mostly
women breaking Japanese
and German codes during the war.
And then I just had to figure
out whether I could find people
and find archival records.
So, a a shout out to
federal agency historians,
because they are wonderful.
[ Applause ]
So, thank you so much.
And I think we have some
descendants of Code Girls
in the audience as well, and I
would just like to thank them
so much for their
mothers' service
and their families'
contributions to our history.
[ Applause ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.